is
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to the 22nd episode of dirty
chess tricks
in this episode i am going to show you
an amazing shock weapon against filter
or black line opening
the modern filido or the black line
opening
arises after the moo order e4 d6
d4 knight to f6 attacking e4 knight to
c3
and now there are two way black can
respond and the first one black can play
the move immediately e5
and after the move knight to f3
black continue here with the move knight
b to d7
now instead of knight b2 d7 black can
also capture the pawn
which is an old main line
but i think after knight captures d4
black position is very passive and among
both the good reply that is g6 and
bishop to e7
i have covered my own reputa in the pgn
so kindly go through the pga where i
have covered this line in the detail
now as per the black line move raputa
here black can continue with the moon
knight b to d7 and after the moon knight
to f3 and e5
we reach the same position
there's a third transposition in this
position while the e4 e5 water so let's
say e4 e5 knight to f3 d6 d4 knight to
f6
knight to c3 and now knight b to d7 we
pretty much reach the same position
now as usual i am going to suggest a
very surprising and aggressive reply by
white and here we are going to continue
with the move bishop to c4
now as i have highlighted over here
black has few choices amongst them
bishop to e7 is the main move but we
should see what happens if you open and
place other moves so the first dubious
move i want to consider is c6 which is
too much surprise even higher end
component has tried this
but after d captures e5 black has just
lost the game in the opening the simple
reason is if we capture back with the
pawn
then after knight to g5
there's a devastation f7 which cannot be
prevented
and if he captured by the knight
then the simplest is you capture this
knight and after pawn captures and
bishop to f7
not only black king will be misplaced
but at this point white is a clear pawn
up
the second move black can try over here
is e captures d4
but after this i am recommending that
you should capture with the queen
and now
black has nothing better than to play
bishop to e7 at this position
anish giri one of the top super gm in
the world
once played this line against a chinese
grandmaster
and here he got ultimate shock after the
moon bishop captures f7
black doesn't have any choice black has
to accept this
but then after knight to g5 it's very
funny that black has the only good move
that is skinned to e8
which
not many of your opponent is going to
find out
anyways i have attached this model game
in the pgn so you can refer it and get a
good idea how to play after bishop
captures f7
finally we come to the move bishop to e7
so black is in the verge of
consolidating his position
but here comes the super surprising move
knight to g5
this is known as nimzovich lara book
variation
and recently this variation comes into
the limelight and black doesn't know the
theory about this variation then he can
straight away demolish in the opening
so let's see what's the idea so first of
all here black is forced to castle
otherwise the epsilon pawn hangs
and after that we are going to continue
with the move bishop captures up seven
it's a check
and black cannot run away with the check
because after king two h8 and knight to
e6
black will simply lose a queen
so that's not possible so that's why
rook f7 is forced and afterwards we are
not going to immediately capture the
rook but we are going to play the move
knight to e6 attacking the queen
queen has the only one spot which is
queen to e8 and after that we are simply
going to capture another pawn which is
knight capture c7
now here black has to play queen to d8
because after queen to f8 and knight
captures rook black has to waste one
more tempo to secure the c7 square
so that's why
queen to d8 is forced at this position
afterwards we are going to capture the
rook in the corner
so let's talk for a moment and find out
what exactly happening in the position
as a white what we have get is we get a
rook and a two pawn for the two mother
piece
and it's very important to understand
what is the plan of the campaign from
the white side
well it is very obvious that we want to
exchange as many as pcs in the game and
we want to reach to the end game where
these two pawns and the rook can majorly
outplay these two minor pieces and this
is pretty much our plan of campaign
now here as i highlighted over here
black has very few limited choices
and against each of them i am going to
show you one of my own model games which
will give you a very good idea how to
play such positions as a
white the first move i want to consider
is b6 which is in fact the most popular
move at this position
but i think it is less accurate and
white can meet this with a tricky move
knight to
b5 black has to be very careful
otherwise
the game can be lost immediately in the
opening
now there are four moves majority lead
try against me
amongst them the main move is a6 but
let's see what is wrong with the other
moves
so the first move i want to consider is
bishop to a6 which looks very initial
because it's attacking two knights but
after white's one reply that is knight
to c7
it's funny that that bishop has to
retrieve back
but after that
our dancing knight comes out from the
black cam with a style so we have here
knight to e6 attacking the queen
queen to c8 knight to g5 attacking the
rock
rook to f8 and after the move knight to
c3 just alien the opening via two pawn
and exchange up
well the same goes with the second move
that is bishop to b7 because after
knight to c7
black has nothing better than a6
but then our dancing knight comes out
with the moon knight to e6 squint c8
knight to g5
pawn captures knight captures king
captures
pawn captures
pawn captures and now f3
where white has obtained two rooks for
the three minor pcs and not to mention
there are some horrible pawn structures
in the black camp
the third move black country over here
is knight to e8 so safeguarding the c7
but against this i'm recommending that
you should continue here with the move
bishop to e3
now to win the piece immediately with
the bishop move is a very bad idea by
black
so let me show you quickly what happens
let's say if we open and place bishop to
a6 then after knight captures b6
knight captures and a4 at this point
white emerged with a three pawn and a
rook for the two pieces which is a more
than a sufficient advantage
and instead of bishop to e6 if you open
and try to move bishop to b7
then after knight captures
pawn captures
and the move d5
this position is even better than the
previous one
the third move black contra over here is
e captures d4 but i don't think so this
will change the scenario because after
the move queen captures d4
somewhere down the line black has to
play bishop moves
let's say bishop to a6 then knight a to
c7
knight captures
knight captures d6
bishop captures queen captures
once again we obtain three pawns in a
rook for two minor pieces
if bishop to b7 at this point then the
simplest is
you capture the spawn and after pawn
captures
and castle on the king side
we again get three pawns and a rook for
the two minor piece
so you can see after knight to b5 it's
not easy for the black to come out from
great difficulties
okay let's consider the most critical
reply by the black over here that is
a6 well after this i'm recommending that
you should continue here with the move
knight to c7
now if allowed then knight to e6 and
both the knight will be escaped so here
black is forced to capture this knight
afterwards we are going to continue here
with the knight to e6
now if you're playing much higher rank
opponent i'm strongly insist over here
that you can take the draw immediately
after repetitions such as queen to e8
knight to c7
queen to d8 knight to e6 and so on
but let's say you are playing this
position against a lower rated or maybe
you are playing for the win
then you can continue with the following
line which is after queen to e8 knight
to g5 attacking the rook rook to f8
and now the move castle on the king side
now to illustrate the plan of the
campaign by the white i am going to show
you one of my own game where my opponent
was 2100 plus rated where he continued
with the move bishop to b7 attacking the
e4 i played f3 and now he continue with
the move queen to g6
no matter i continue here with the move
knight to e6 attacking the rook
rook to c8
and now very important move d5
well obviously black is ahead in the
development at this position but if you
carefully look at the black pieces they
are very much cramped and they don't
have much scope
and that's where our advantage lies
my opponent continue here with the moon
knight to c5 i captured this piece which
at first sight looks horrible because
it's straight in a black pawn structure
but i have a specific idea in the mind
here i continue with the move c3
my opponent played bishop to a6
i played rook to f2 so getting out of
any discoveries
he continued with the move knight to h5
but i think this knight to h5 knight to
f4 idea is very slow and i can
immediately exploit it with the move a4
my opponent indeed played the move
knight to f4
and it is very obvious that just like
sicilian whenever this knight arrives is
on c4 or f4 we are going to chop up this
knight with the move bishop captures
after pawn captures and the move e5
i think black is in a trouble
now obviously this is a pawn sacrifice
and after some calculation my opponent
indeed accept it
but after that i continue with the a
captures b5 and after bishop captures b5
i come out with a very nasty move that
is d6
well what to do
well the simple idea is if black capture
this pawn then after queen to b3 he is
going to lose a piece
and apart from that the best move over
here which is played my opponent that is
bishop to h4 so his idea is to counter
attacking me
but after queen check
queen to f7
rook to d2
queen has been exchanged
bishop to f6
rook to a7
bishop to c4 attacking the rogue
but after the fight's next reply that is
d7
black position is already losing
the simple reason is after rook to d8
rook capture c5 attacking the bishop
bishop to e6 and now the move b4 this is
exactly i was talking about at the early
stage
white has this majority on the queen
side and what we want to do is that
these two pawns and a rope can clearly
outplay these two minor pieces
and in fact the game finished very
quickly so let me show you the rest of
the moves very quickly my opponent
captured this pawn i played rook to d5
pinning that bishop so black has not
many good options he continue here with
the move bishop to ea but after hook
captures bishop captures rook to e8
he gave me this check and after king to
f1 and king to f7 this is completely
winning end game for the white
rook to b8 bishop to e3 b5 k7 b6 bishop
to b5
c4 a very good move bishop capture c4
king to even king to d7 b7
king to c7 and now the star move rook to
c8 which not only nab a piece but the
resulting end game is completely winning
the second move black and try over here
is e captures d4 but i think this is
probably the most easiest variation you
have to handle because after queen
captures d4
we are already attacking a7 and black
response is forced here black has to
play moves such as b6
well after that we are going to continue
here with the move bishop to e3
kindly note if bishop to a6 then queen
to a4 is a very strong reply so the best
move over here is bishop to b7
but then we can immediately capture this
pawn and after pawn captures and castle
on the king side
not only white has achieved three pawn
and a rook for two minor pieces
but the most important factor is
black has some severe pawn weaknesses on
the queen side
in the pgn i have included a game of
mine against a free day master
which will give you an idea how it
should continue from here onwards
now the third and the most critical
reply try by the black over here is b5
this is a direct attempt from black to
refute the white opening idea
now the first thing you should note over
here is you cannot capture this pawn
because after queen check and knight
comes back and then black plays knight
captures e4
black is completely winning in such a
position
so you are not going for the pawn
grabbing but instead of that i'm
recommending that you should continue
here with the move f3
obviously black has three different good
choices but against each of them
white obtained a very good position
so the first move i want to consider is
a6
which in a way saving that pawn
here white has a good reply that is d
captures e5 kindly note if knight
captures e5 then after the move bishop
to e3
that knight can easily escape
knight to d7 doesn't help it because
after knight to d5
there is enough support for that knight
to come out
so knight captures e5 is not possible at
this point so black has to capture with
the pawn
and then we are going to continue here
with the move knight to d5
so now white is all set to arrange
evacuation for the knight
so black has to stop it and the only
good way to stop it is to capture this
knight but after that queen captures d5
will give white a winning position
i read this position against 1900 rated
opponent where my opponent continued
with the move bishop to c5 so he stopped
my castle
but never mind i continue here with the
move bishop to d2 and after the move
queen to e7 which has an idea of knight
to f6
but after white's next reply that is
queen to c6
attacking the bishop at the same time
supporting the c7 square
black is completely busted he continued
with the move queen to f8 but after
knight to c7
he realized that he is an exchange down
for not a single compensation
in short a6 gives a very good advantage
to the white
so let's look at some of the critical
reply by black the first move i want to
consider is bishop to a6
so idea is not only to regain the peace
but in some lines if white castle on the
king's side then b4 occurs with a tempo
so as a white you need to play a very
careful chess here i'm recommending that
you should continue with the move a4
attacking the b4 immediately
and after the obvious reply b4 you
should continue with the move knight to
d5
so now if allowed the knight to c7 will
definitely on the card
so black has to capture our piece
after that i'm recommending that you
should continue with the move knight to
c7
this is a case of my game against a w i
aim where she continued here with the
move queen to b7 i captured her
dangerous bishop she recaptured with the
queen
and now the good move d captures e5
kindly note if knight captures e5 then
queen to e2 and not only white is
exchanging everything but
it will give black a horrible pawn
structure
so in the game she decided to capture
with the pawn but after that i continue
with the move bishop to e3
my opponent continue with the move
bishop to c5
i play queen to e2 so hitting the queen
and if the queen i exchanged as i
mentioned earlier this position is quite
favorable to the white
my opponent played queen to d6 i simply
castle on the king side and now she
continue with the move a5
so once again we reached to the same
scenario where white has a 2.0 rook for
the two minor pieces
and this game will give you a very good
insight how one should continue
here i get a tempo on the queen with the
rook f to d1
my opponent played queen to c7
i captured his bishop she captured with
the queen i parked my king in the corner
and now she continued with the move at
6.
well so far we are defending but now
it's our turn to attack and after some
calculation i decided to open up the
position with the move c3
obviously this is a pawn sack which my
opponent indeed accept the challenge
but my idea is now to play rook d to c1
so now i have some open lines for my
rook and it turns out that this is very
very deadly for her
she responded with the moon queen to b4
and now simple plan yeah we want to
exchange the queen and reach to the end
game where this position is quite
favorable to the white
my opponent responded here with the move
rook to f8 so she desperately want to
activate his rook but after queen
captures pawn captures
rook to b4 attacking the pawn rook to b8
and now rook to p3 so it's very
important to block at that pawn
my opponent continue with the moon king
to f7
so desperately want to defend queenside
with the king
but after rook two c4 it is very obvious
that
that b-pawn is going down
my opponent continue with his king
journey which is king to e6 i captured
the pawn and after rook captures and
rook captures
at first sight it looks like black can
easily handle that pawn with the two
knights
but in fact this position is completely
winning
my opponent continued here with the moon
knight to e8
i played a5
she played knight to c5
so stopping a6
but it's just an illusion because a6
does happens
and it's funny that knight cannot
capture because of the simple rook check
my opponent desperately tried to rescue
the position with the two knight so she
played knight to c7 i continue with the
a7
and you can see the potential of this
position last four moves pawn moves and
still black cannot able to capture that
pawn with the knight
she played king to d7 but after rook to
b8 the position is already gone
few moves has been played knight to a6
promoting with the queen and after night
captures and rook captures
she just resigned at this position
in the view of white has an exchange and
a clear pawn advantage
now the third and the final black can
try over here is bishop to b7
so idea is to capture the knight
immediately
well here you have two choices
you can capture the pawn or you can play
the move d5
now knight captures b5 is completely
fine for the white and i have included
the whole line in the pgl but the move
which i favor over the knight to b5 is
d5
the simple reason is this will
completely block the mobility of black
pieces
now if your opponent plays moves such as
b4 then knight e2 is always a good move
so in this game where my opponent was a
feed a master he continued with the move
a6
no matter i continue with the moon b4 so
stopping any b4 advancement by black
he captured my piece
and i responded immediately on the queen
side with the moon a4
my opponent counter attacked my knight
with the queen to c8
i defended with the move bishop to d2
and now indeed he has to pay attention
on the queen side
finally he decided to capture the spawn
but after night captures white is
obviously in the good shape
he continued with the move knight to h5
so same idea that is knight to f4
but we don't bother we just castle on
the king's side and after the move
knight to f4 even we don't need to
capture that knight over here because we
can continue here with the moon g3
and funny enough black doesn't have any
good option except going back on the g6
so black has wasted so many tempos and
this is all happens because of that
wonderful moon d5
i continue here with the moon queen to
e2
so it's a cheap trap that if black
captured this pawn
then after rook f2 c1 queen to b3 and
rook to c3
black simply lose a queen
obviously he doesn't fall for that
instead of that he continue with the
move bishop to d8
i responded with the move rook f2 c1
and now
he tried to resolve his cram pieces with
the move knight to b6
but i think it's a bad idea because this
is exactly what it wants as after the
move c4
white plan on the queenside campaign is
already running down
my opponent here capture my knight i
recapture with the rook
and now he continue with the rook to c7
so his idea is to stop me to play c5
but to his surprise
yep c5 indeed happen
and you should always consider this move
if you have a good tactics in the
position
my idea is when my opponent has to
forcefully capture this pawn i want to
play the moon d6
so attacking the rook
there's only one way to hang on to this
pawn by playing the moon rook to c7
but then i continue with the queen check
king to h8 and now wonderful center and
two pawn advantage
and look at the black
horrible horrible pieces
in fact the game finished within few
moves he continued with the move queen
to d7 rook to b4
knight to f8
bishop to e3
a5 attacking the rook rook to b3
and the critical mistake happened at the
move knight to e6
before i move on i like you to pause
this video and find out what is wrong
with the move knight to e6
okay i hope you find this easiest
continuation that is rook captures b7
queen captures b7 and queen captures e6
not only simplifying the position with a
great advantage but white has a concrete
threat of fin to e8
which not only threatening a checkmate
but as well as grabbing a piece
and black cannot defend both the threat
that's it guys
i hope with this brief analysis
now you are confident enough to play
this line
this line has a great surprise value and
not many filido players are ready for it
i have personally gone through so many
videos and books and there are hardly
any mention of this line
remember the plan of campaign which i
have suggested throughout the video that
you are trying to exchange as many as
pieces and going into the end game where
this rook and two or maybe three pawns
clearly outplayed your opponent's two
minor pieces and you get a great
advantage in the clock as well
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on my video and i'll meet you in my next
episode very soon
bye and take care
and it contains lots of tricks
once again black has few options
but believe it or not they all leads to
a very miserable position
and it's a great fun to watch all of
them so let's see each by turn
and still white is going to play this
amazing stunner that is
d5
it's just like indirectly saying to the
white sorry buddy d5 is mine